hello everyone and welcome back to the
nations cup and here we have eleven
aragón against Vida - once again
yeah so let's see what happened this
game really features a move I you know
what one like I haven't seen in a very
long time so without further ado eleven
opens wit Knight to f3 he goes for the
array t opening and we have d5 here by
with it with III somewhat rare removed
in g3 but also also played on the
highest level
we have c5 and C for now immediately
challenging the center we have d4 a
video to grabs more space in the center
and we have characters captures and here
Bishop to d3 by level not going for d3
and then having this sort of a passive
setup for white but instead after C
captors and before we have Bishop to d3
with ideas of maybe shifting the bishop
over to c2 in the future so with it
continues with the knight to c6 and 11
just castles here we have Knight to f6
and Bishop the c2 now so it's not a new
idea it has been used before we have
Bishop to g4 by vidit and now there is
one game in the database where d3 was
played but here 11 plays Bishop to a4
and it is a new move in the position so
already as a move eight we have a
completely new game and the idea is that
if black is maybe a bit too hasty in
grabbing the center with E 5 then you
can go h3 and force a trade here you can
run you can win the bishop pair because
if you go then maybe a wife can just the
harass your Bishop and win the 5 point
since the night here is pinned so here
you would have to trade and then white
just wins the bishop pair straight from
the beginning of the game so instead
avidity goes Knight to d7 he doesn't
allow this pin to exist and now it will
not be a problem so Levin still
continues with h3 but now Bishop to h5
Vidia tips the bishop pair and now d3 we
have E 5 now it is ok to grab the center
and rook to e1 putting more pressure on
d5 pawn the King is also still in the
center of the board so brush up the e7
and now Knight B to d2 by 11 we have
castles by with it and Knight to e4 now
and here Queen to c7 it would be a bit
too early to go f5 here because after 9
g3 this comes with tempo so after the
bishop moves you're actually very happy
here you have a triple control over the
e4 square so you don't have to worry
about e4 and you really don't care about
that for and just you know you can go
back with the knight doesn't really
matter
so just Queen to c7 navigate nicely
develops the Queen connects the rooks
and now a3 preparing further expansion
and the Queen side which of it it
prevents with a 5 and now Knight to g3
going after the bishop you maneuvering
the knight push it back to g6 and here
11 gives up the light square Bishop will
rush of cactus and c6 be captures Enda
now going for this pawn grab with Knight
captures on d4 so this wins upon but the
d4 the d4 pawn will be well really
stifling Levin's development as you'll
see so II capture Sundy for we have
route captures an e7 and now Queen to d6
attacking the rook will group back to e2
not the e1 probably after the Queen and
Bishop are developed you wanna double up
rooks on the e-file so to save time with
Knight the c5 now with a double attack
on the d3 pawn and Knight to e4 blocking
off this attack so Knight characters on
e4 we have D captures on e4 now with it
has a past D pawn and rook F to e8 now
putting more pressure to the pawn and
here 11 defends it with f3 and now a for
not allowing any b4 ideas in the future
and here if we can get this c5 moving
for example if you try something like
Bishop d2 to go here or some like that
then c5 comes and it's just a very nice
position for black this pawn structure
here really prevents 11 from doing much
and the village committee does have a
passport here you have you will have to
worry about the b2 upon in the future
and so on so instead Levin decides to
give back the pawn and he plays c5 and
by doing so he gains the DF 4 square for
his Bishop and also the c1 square for
his rook which would come with tempo
that's okay
we have Queen characters on c5 you have
to eliminate the pawn move the Queen and
then start pushing your C pawn and
Bishop to f4 now and it's it's a really
tricky idea Bishop therefore
because what if black plays d3 so this
theory comes with to check although we
don't win the rook
for example rook can move to e3 and then
you've defended your rook you're gonna
move the King and then this will may be
a target however black does have this
Bishop captures an e4 idea and after
let's say pawn captures you can again
capture here temporary sacrifice a piece
but you will able to win it back since
the bishop has nowhere to go and if you
go somewhere else where rather than
being here than just the rook or Queen
captures on e3 so here we'd probably see
something like rook c1 Queen would still
move here keep an eye on this diagonal
and after Queen captures and b3 rook
with capture and f4 and you get this
game where black is up upon so it is
possible for vivid to pull d3 however he
decides for Queen to b6 he just wants to
start pushing the C pawn and we have
looked the c1 now we have c5 by with it
and now rook the c-4 stopping the
further pushing of the C pawn and also
preparing Queen C want to go after the
c5 pawn with f6 keeping an eye on the e5
square and now Queen the c1 going after
the c5 square we have looked at a 5
defending and here at 11 just goes
rookie eat the c2 with a triple attack
on the pawn which makes it impossible
for black to defend let's it would work
see it because just rook captures here
and now you cannot to recapture
basically it's a free pawn so instead of
it it decides to strike back in the
center with f5 we have root cap person
c5 eleven grabs his pawn rook captures
on c5 we have rook captures and only now
F captures on e4 11 recap force on e4
and now here with it it doesn't capture
back with the bishop for example Bishop
captures any 4 because you get Quincy 4
check and you pick up the d4 pawn king
HH we're gonna pick up this pawn and now
you don't have any any further ways of
attacking the rook there - maybe exploit
this pin of course if rook c8 you just
get made it so instead a visit place
pawn to d3 first now the idea is that
okay you can give a check but you can't
grab the pawn because the rook is
hanging so we have brush up the e3
instead now threating some nasty
discoveries and of course if it it moves
the Queen we have Quinta east 6 and now
rook the c7 here
decides to give up d4 pawn yeah well
it's not like you can defend it but at
least he will get a very active square
for his rook we have Queen captures on
e4 ending out Russia back to d2 blocking
off this this past bond with h6 of idiot
create some room for his for his king
and now Queen to c5 repairing bishop to
c3 we have Bishop to f7 now as you know
Bishop is coming to c3 so there will be
a lot of pressure here going towards the
g7 pawn and Bishop the c3 now and here
we get a case when you have bishops of
opposite colors of course if it's a
bishops bishop of opposite color endgame
then it's most most likely a draw unless
it's not but when it's when which we
have Queens on the board rooks on the
board and bishops of opposite colors on
the board then it's important to always
be the side that's attacking so here you
can see that xi really has a lot of
pressure going on towards the g7 pawn
and the LightSquared Bishop is unable to
oppose the dark square bishop so it's
basically like the side defending is
down a piece when we have attacks
involving bishops of opposite colors so
a visitor will try to set up sort of a
sort of a battery of his own he goes a
Queen to g6
we have looked the East 7 by 11 now
going for a rook trade here we have rook
captures Queen captures now you can't
really move the Queen and Bishop from
here otherwise you're getting checkmated
on g7 and the King to h7 now now we have
Queen to e5 again keeping an eye on this
pawn here and now the video also wants
to create a setup like this so he was
Bishop to yet he wants to get his Bishop
over here to Buddha putted the same
amount of pressure to the g2 pawn but 11
says I don't really care about that he
goes King f2 and our point is if you go
brush up the c6 white can just play g4
and then maybe you can go after the the
d3 pawn just pick it up and maybe have a
winning endgame so instead we have the
shabak to f7 with it just decides to
wait and see what happens and the g4 now
we have Bishop back to b3 and kink the
e3 by 11 with Russia back to C to end
came to d2 and here if it it just
repeats better back to b3 the Queen and
Bishop regard these pawns nicely so
nothing to worry about here 11 repeats
- III we've pushed back the c2 and King
2d to visit repeats once again Bishop to
b3 and here 11 sets a little trap for
for vidit he plays Queen to e7 and okay
nothing much changed obviously you're
still like from the e5 square you're
still putting pressure on the g7 point
if the Queen moves obviously it's
checkmate and the villa just needs to
waste a move and most likely we will
have a a draw by repetition however you
need to waste a move with moves like
Bishop to c4 Bishop to d5 Bishop to e6
and so on however we did decided to
waste a move with Bishop to see - once
again but now Levin had a different idea
so feel free to pause the video and try
to find this winning idea at 11:00
played while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on being
as creative as 11 over the board and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's be for a completely winning
the point is that with it says okay I
mean you do have a task bone now
obviously we can't have that so just it
captures on b3 I'm Poisson it's a free
pawn
however 11 also plays a move that if you
saw at the moment when you played b4
then really just hats off to you
Bishop to b2 with this move he prevents
the pawn from being pushed forward and
traps the light square bishop so now the
light square bishop has no squares I
mean you could go here just repeat moves
but this Bishop is not seeing the light
of day for the rest of the game and
Elevens plan is now very clear he's
gonna push a 4 a 5 a 6 a 7 and window
game because after the pond reaches a 6
you cannot capture it since there's the
main threat you know just happening
there on g7 so with it tried h5 but
Levin just doesn't give him any moves g5
we have h4 but now just a 4 by 11 and
here there are no moves for video to be
played
there's no move you can play the g5 pawn
nicely guarded by the Queen so not not
much to be done here he tried King g8
but now a5
we have King to h7 and now a 6
of course you cannot capture because
there's checkmate on g7 so Bishop the d1
a last try by visit trying to give up
the bishop to maybe try and get the
Queen into the game but lemon says thank
you for the bishop we have d2 and now of
course you could continue the game in a
lot of different ways but once again
feel free to pause the video and finish
the game in the simplest way possible
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on your use of
simplicity and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's of course
Queen captures and g7
get the Queen's off the board and then
you're a pawn is just winning so here we
did played Queen captures with Bishop
capture screen captures and after king
capture son beat you was played it was
in this position that we did resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here next move is just a seven
eight Queen and of course that's a
completely winning game so it's really
really remarkable how in a rapid game 11
was able to create such a such an
amazing threat here after this after
this Queen to e7 idea that if you don't
allow your Bishop to be trapped with
Bishop the c2 like if you go go shop c4
or anywhere along this diagonal then
before doesn't work black and just grab
a pawn and your Bishop is still free to
move but with this with it was probably
on autopilot just repeating moves as
there there is no way to break through
in the position here but Levin found it
a beautiful before and it's just game
over and it's trapping the bishop like
this this is just this is just beautiful
so it's great to see 11a back at the
board especially after that terrible
terrible misfortune that that happened
to his wife
and yeah it's just good to good to see
him back playing play not only playing
chess but playing brilliant chess like
this yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
and this brilliant Bishop trapping
maneuver yeah I I would like to thank
Panos Timothy Otis the Dean really equal
Rebecca Julian you're subs are in the
Martin Chernykh for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the nation's
Cup and
whatever else I I manage the time for
sure I think I will see soon and have an
excellent rest of your day